Don't study the basics in English!
Why?
Intentionally studying the so-called "basics" in English
is a waste of time!
Because learning vocabulary
is a natural process.
Gradually, bit by bit,
the language comes into our brains.
Don't try to build a language like a house,
with a foundation, a wall, and a roof.
Languages are not houses!
Depending on the situation, extremely basic things
still take a long time for us to get accustomed to.
I have studied 20 foreign languages
and have experienced this process many times.
For example, when I speak Japanese...
I lived in Japan for 9 years.
So when I speak Japanese,
I don't really have any major problems.
I can say what I want to say,
and I can understand what others are saying.
But I still make basic mistakes.
And that is not a problem!
You have a mother tongue, perhaps Japanese or French,
and when you study English,
grammar structures
the use of words
Which do we get used to first?
Which comes next?
There is a natural order of acquisition.
Trying to deliberately memorize something
doesn't work.
Instead, you should naturally
listen a lot
and read a lot
Without feeling resistance
The attitude of thinking
"I want to deliberately study!"
will only lead to frustration.
Instead, choose fun, interesting content
and listen and read a lot
Even if you forget again and again,
even if you don't understand the same part that you listen to,
even if you don't understand what you read,
even if you forget words you thought you had already learned
even if you forget words when you read
even if you forget words when you try to speak
If you don't remember
that's totally okay!
For example, in English
I go, you go, he goes
You only add an "s" for "he goes"
That is a very simple rule
But even thought it's a simple rule,
a lot of English learners make mistakes.
And this is not just for Japanese people.
Many other foreign learners of English
struggle with the third person singular
This "He / she goes."
But for the purpose of communication,
this is not a problem.
Learning vocabulary is a matter of getting used to it.
The word "study" itself [in Japanese]
if you look at the characters
(and I also speak Chinese)
these Chinese characters originally meant
"having to do things you don't want to do"
Study like that,
in which you intentionally struggle along,
doesn't work!
Instead, the fundamental way to study is to get used to the language.
If you do so, you will be able to...
For example, in the case of English, you don't have any English habits to begin with.
Because it's a foreign language,
it's important to learn the right habits.
With a great deal of time,
you gradually move away from the habits of your native language.
And acquire the new language.
In  my case, going from English to Japanese habits.
In the case of Japanese people, from Japanese to English.
Getting used to this new environment takes time.
Acquisition takes time.
Consciously trying to study the basics doesn't work.
This is true for words
and it's true for grammar.
When it comes to words, it's often said that
if you understand 1,000 words,
no matter the sentence,
no matter the content,
you can understand 80%.
But what happens if you memorize this basic vocabulary?
The result?
In most conversations
and for most content, sentences, and texts,
these 1,000 words will not be sufficient.
That last 30 percent is extremely important!
So be patient
Take your time
And little by little
as you listen and read a lot
the words will come in.
High-frequency words
because their frequency is so high
because they appear so frequently
they will eventually be remembered.
So don't worry about trying to deliberately memorize these basic words as a goal.
Don't worry so much
and just keep going.
Oh, and one more thing...
Asking someone to correct ones mistakes
is useless.
Even if you are corrected
you will still make the same mistakes.
That is, you will continue to make the same mistakes until you get used to the pattern.
So just like a 2 or 3-year-old child
who makes mistakes when they start speaking
the brain will gradually correct the patterns naturally without formal correction.
Even if 6 months pass, or a year passes,
of studying English
even if you always forget vocabulary
or make basic mistakes
this is totally natural and normal!
It's always this way.
Even as I've studied various languages,
the same thing has happened.
So don't study the basics!
Instead, listen and read more.
And please speak if you have the chance.
Don't feel pressure.
It's a long-term battle,
so just keep studying.
It's okay if you forget the basics,
but don't try to learn them deliberately.
See you later.